Speaker 1: We've been talking
about when in the COVID pandemic,
does it become a Republican virus in the United
States? Why would it become a Republican virus?
Well, three reasons. Number one, Republicans are
far less willing to get vaccinated than everybody
else. Number two, Republicans are less willing to
wear masks than everybody else, and number three,
Republicans are less willing to accept and
participate in other sorts of precautions
physical distancing, reducing crowd sizes,
provisions in schools, etc. than others. So
over time, we would think this might become
a Republican pandemic in the United States.
You look at Republican governors, Republican
governors are much less likely to require vaccines
or to go with vaccine requirements in their
states. And two, they're much less likely to
put in place mat or to support mask mandates in
their states and to support other precautions. So
we've been saying for months, to some degree,
it's probably already a Republican virus in the
United States, more so than anything else based
on those numbers. And now we have the proof.
The New York Times just released a map of the
COVID death rate since June 16, so this is
roughly the last 100000 120000 deaths. Deaths from
June 16 forward June July, August, September. OK.
It looks like a map of Republican voters. We
have the we have the map up on the screen.
The map that we have on the screen could be a
map of where people voted for Donald Trump most
heavily. It's actually a map of where we've
seen the highest per capita COVID death rates
over the last hundred or 120000 deaths. And in
fact, we can put up on the screen side by side
the map of the last 100000 deaths per capita,
100000 deaths on a per capita basis on the left
and on the right, a map that shows
support for Donald Trump versus Joe Biden
by blue and red dots. Now I know that a ton
of people will say, Hold on a second, David.
Whoa, whoa, whoa. Hold on, sir. The
states with the most per capita deaths
are blue states. Remember, it's New York, it's New
Jersey, it's Massachusetts. For a little while,
it was California. First of all, that's no
longer true. So that might have been true
seven months ago. If you now look at the top
15 states by per capita COVID death rate today,
you'll see that now it's a ton of red states.
The reddest Mississippi has the highest per
capita death rate, New Jersey still there. Then
you've got Louisiana, Alabama, Florida, Arkansas,
Georgia, South Carolina, South Dakota, Indiana.
It's more and more red states. What happened?
What happened is exactly what we've been
predicting from day one. Early before we knew
anything about the virus when it was too early
to know what to do. This was a new pandemic.
The places that had the bad luck to be early
infected places did the worst by far. These were
places that were connected by direct flights to
China and to the parts of Europe that had early
spread like Italy and a few other countries. So
overwhelmingly that meant the big airport gateways
on the East Coast, New York and Boston. At one
point it was Calif- California, to some degree,
Illinois with Chicago Airport and so many
United and American Airlines flights to the
places with the early spread. Those
are all blue states blue cities.
But over time, as we learn more about how do
you suppress spread, what does and doesn't work?
We saw blue states get more vaccinated
than red states, and we saw blue states
where more matt more or more masks and the like,
we expected that the deaths would start to move
over to red states on a per capita basis. Once the
virus was everywhere, rather than the chance of
what places had the flights to China and Italy
early on, we expected the deaths would shift to
the places that are not getting vaccinated and
are not wearing masks. And that is now happening
plain and simple. The last 100000 deaths have
been most heavy, as you can see on the map
in Florida, Georgia, South Carolina, Alabama,
Mississippi, Louisiana, Arkansas, Missouri, Texas.
You get the picture, so there's nothing surprising
here. The shock is how political the deaths have
gotten. Now, of course, liberals in red states
are dying, too. Of course, conservatives in blue
states are dying, too. But this is the trend.
This should really scare the Republican Party,
not because they care about people dying. I
don't know if they do. Maybe they do. Maybe
they don't. They don't seem to. But maybe they
do. But this should scare the Republican Party
because it can't be good for winning elections
to see your voters disproportionately be the
ones dying from a pandemic that you are failing
to do the things that public health experts
say should be done in order to control it. It's
not possible to miss when you look at that map,
how the deaths the last 100000 120000 deaths
are aligning with voting trends. Vaccination
against a 100 year pandemic virus is now a test of
political allegiance. It is an incredible thing,
and unfortunately it seems like this is going
to be the trend for some period of time. Cases
continue to decline that that'll benefit
everybody. But it seems like it is really
not good in many of these red states. And I guess
I was naive. I thought something like this might
actually cross party lines and people would just
come together and listen to public health experts
and doctors. But no, I was wrong again. I was
the naive buffoon. Hey, listen. On October 19th,
Tuesday, October 19th, we're doing something
very special. We are doing a live town hall.
This will be exclusively on the new David Pakman
Show YouTube channel on the second channel called
Packman Live. Six p.m. EST 3:00 p.m. West on
Tuesday, October 19th. We will be doing a live
town hall. All questions will be open. Members
will get priority in the queue to talk to me and
to ask questions. This will not be on the main
YouTube channel. This will not be on Twitch or
Twitch, as some people call it. It will not be on
Facebook. This will be on the Pacman Live YouTube
channel. Find it at youtube.com slash Pacman Live
or David Pakman dot com slash Pacman Live. They
both go to the same place market in your calendar.
Tuesday, October 19, six p.m.. Exclusive Pacman
Live only town hall. And in the meantime, always
you can let me know what kind of crazy high
jinks people are up to with masks and vaccines in
your state by finding me on Twitter at De Pacman